Hello,我是小专临助,大家中秋节快乐!
今天我要分享三款效果很好,能够让皮膚变得又戏又滑,而且线效很快的精凡
如果你现在是正在长闭口,或者是你感觉现在的练护状态,有点不平正
又或者是你想要皮膚的这个质感变得更好
那你一定要开今天这一天,我会跟你们说这三款精凡怎么使用,让他们效果又滑就好
让抚致在短时间内提升很多,即使这三型老粉应该都见过很多次了
但是因为我真的是很喜欢他们,他们效果很好
所以这次我单独的临出来说
先说这款六三精凡,这款我也经常用了一两年了
这一款精凡就是可以让你的皮膚发生一个质的变化
我只要用他要我的皮膚就能保持在一个非常健康漂亮的战产
就是早上你起床去上镜子,你就会发现你的皮膚好吸引好光滑,好有光子
我在想说路的第一个视频里面就有提到他,你们可以去考古
大家时就几个斗机粉子去买了,他们全部都来感谢我说现在皮膚变得好好啊
但是呢他有点猛,他叫六酸精凡,里面是有六酸
我特别喜欢他的一点,是他除了能够让我的肌膚平滑,吸引之外
可能里面因为有人二酸的加入,所以我用他用了一段时间之后,我发现我就算长了那种红种大豆
我的豆腐也稍得非常快,我感觉他是有渠道硬的效果的,而且效果还很好
那他要怎么用呢,我喜欢在晚间或喝水和酥腐精凡之后,用他用个这么一滴
在我脸上容易长闭口斗斗,好像是这么脚后不平滑,不吸你的区域,薄薄的涂上一层就好
后面再加一个清爽的,把身边伤就可以了
我这样用他从来都没有翻车过
如果你们是一个耐受皮,那你一定要试一下这款精凡
然后就是这款幸运人三精凡,我觉得这款适合你的脸上脚就很厚,皮膚粗超暗淡无光,然后又很爱长一些闭口粉丝的宝宝
我这片是8%的,他不算猛,健康的皮膚应该都可以用,里面有5%的幸运算百分之二的水羊算和百分之一的焦菩酸
我之前在提不着所我的医生就给我开了幸运算让我们家用,但他给我开了好贵啊
我觉得他们家心想你更高我就换成了这个,这一品最好是在晚上洗完脸了之后干手干脸
第一步,塗在脸上一些脚子在比较厚的区域
这样不会破坏他的这个骗取直,效果是最好的
后续在擦上一些收户的精华面窗
我自己是这样用个两三天我的皮膚就会开始微微的脱皮了
那我跟你们说,想如果我们的脸上脱皮,但是没有任何的不是的症状
那这个脱皮都是一个很好的现象
我皮膚一身就是要让我的脸脱皮,因为脱完这层死皮之后,我们的脸就会变得很嫩,很滑
很吸引你而且会变得很亮,最后就是这款RB
这款是和给一些无法耐受A重,虽然这种猛药的贵复门
这一品精华的效果真的很好,而且健晓也很快
0.01%的白铃铃铃纯,所以它的抗凉化和提亮效果非常好
而且没有什么刺激性,完全不用担心用它不翻车
我用完它第二天我就感觉哇,赛我洗脸的时候感觉皮膚的这个处感就不一样了
就感觉它效果好好啊
我乎乎一项是比较极的
那种腰肉很久才能看得出效果的那种乎乎品我没有什么耐心去用它
我喜欢尽效快的,但是一般尽效快的又比较猛
这个我感觉就是它尽效又快,然后又温泼
它真的让我的膚致有变得更好,在用它期间我的皮膚又白又亮
它的抗凉化的效果真的很强
好了,那我这三款非常喜欢的,把我放进化,我就分享给你们了
如果你们还有什么想看的可以跟我留言哦
那我们下期见,拜拜